Kristen's like oh that [ __ ] house of
dragon [ __ ] is and I'm like what is that
I was like is this a new reality show I
don't even know and she's like it's that
Game of Thrones thing but it's 300 years
earlier and I'm like dude I didn't even
like Game of Thrones now I gotta watch
not even after it before it it's gonna
be more boring they got less [ __ ]
probably as time moves on there's more
[ __ ] and I gotta watch the prequel to
something where they barely had anything
except dragons that didn't even show up
until the [ __ ] Fifth Season by the
way dude
fourth season whatever it was dude I
[ __ ] watched it and there were no
dragons and then by the fourth season
there was finally like one or two
dragons and I got I was like this is
what I've been waiting for I'm out dude
I'm out
and people about the thing they're like
dude you were you you left right when it
gets good hey Four Seasons
if I I [ __ ] order a burger and 11
bites are bad I'm done
now keep eating bro just wait
foreign
[Music]
I [ __ ] up with that burger
so I'm watching the [ __ ] uh so she's
like let's put it on come on and she
doesn't even want to watch it in the
[ __ ] room I want to watch it in which
is the worst bro you know I'm like can
we just watch it with the fireplace and
have it nice we don't even want the
fireplace on it's hot as [ __ ] and our
air conditioning doesn't work but I'm
like can we just have it on the in the
[ __ ] in where the fireplace is dude
and uh and she's like no I want to watch
it like where this is and I'm like
[ __ ] God and and the show I don't
want to watch
but okay though dude you know what I
mean
even though we did Color Me Mine and I
didn't really want to do that and yes I
had a good time and a lovely time with
my son and I did that uh and that wasn't
one of my things that I wanted to do
yeah I still [ __ ] said okay and we
watched the show in the room that I
didn't want to watch and that's fine but
I sucked it up and I watched it and dude
I can't I don't know what it is about
this [ __ ] I cannot pay attention to
these kinds of shows for more than four
[ __ ] seconds
it's it's like there's so much Brown in
it
and it's like you know there's no voice
over for sure and then like a dragon and
then like I'm like I you know
what it's just like in the house of drag
I mean Targaryen and that's when it and
the in 300 years and the [ __ ] and
you're just watching this [ __ ] and
you're like all right okay and then a
guy walks in with long as [ __ ] blonde
hair and you're like all right no it's
white sorry long [ __ ] white hair and
you're like ah cool all right that's
kind of an interesting looking guy
and then it cuts to the other guy he's
talking to and the other guy's got long
as [ __ ] white hair and they just are
like talking to each other
and then they say well like wait we have
to talk to the other guy in the [ __ ]
other room and then they go to another
room and there's [ __ ] three guys and
they all got like long white hair and
then a black guy comes in and he's got
long white hair and I'm just like
they're not nobody's gonna say anything
about this long white hair in the
beginning of I understand they live with
it but say something for us
it's like when when when Jason Momo is
in a movie this is what my brother
always says but like when Jason Momo is
in a movie why aren't there at least two
or three scenes in every one of his
movies where somebody says whoa dude
you're huge
you're huge
let's get past he's too big to be in
movies you know
Jason Momoa is gonna just like play a
guy
but you're seven feet tall 980.
might you weigh more than a Humvee too
sorry sir you weigh more than a than an
H2
foreign
that one time I saw Jason Momoa before
he was a movie star when I just knew
about a guy that got a part to the new
Conan movie
and I saw him and I thought oh that's
Jason Momoa and I was right
and that is the God's honest truth dude
and I was with Brian Cowan and he walked
up to him he was like wow man you're a
big dude I swear but you know he's
obsessed with bodies but that's what
happens when Jason Momoa walks into a
room
maybe if he's Aquaman okay he's a
superhero but dude you know
if he's just a guy with a gun and [ __ ]
like he's in a movie with Sylvester
Stallone I saw on a plain one because
that is one plane watching ass movie
dude I mean if you're gonna watch up
what are the most two actors that you
would watch that would be in a movie in
a plane
because that's the thing too it's like
it wouldn't be the number one it
wouldn't be like like you think of a
[ __ ] a Jeremy Renner movie you think
oh that's a big movie star I would go to
the movie theater for him because I love
him right
but then if you couple him with with a
certain person you might be like ah I'll
wait for that at home
dude it's very few stars that have that
all go no matter what
right no matter who they're coupled with
like you know what I mean
wow that's [ __ ] hilarious
like if you [ __ ] couple like Jason if
you go see Jason Momoa movie you might
go to the theater because it's gonna be
Aquaman it's gonna be whatever the [ __ ]
Dune if you see yourself as a Stallone
movie maybe not now but back in the day
dude you would go it would be a
blockbuster I love Sylvester Stallone
but you put those both [ __ ] in
a movie and that [ __ ] is best seen on a
screen that's eight by twelve
but Jason Momo was just gonna play the
guy with a gun that walks in a warehouse
and Sylvester Stallone's not gonna be
like whoa this guy's really big huh
he's just gonna be like hey
huh
so do it for us
House of dragons
well that's because we've all got white
hair right and that's why because we all
got really really [ __ ] there was the
age of the age of of terrify remember
that when the [ __ ] when the when when
the Devil Himself rose up and scared all
of our ancestors and everyone went white
hair and that's what happened and now we
all have the white hair anyway who will
we beheading
[Music]
for real sounds just like tutors dude
chrisley.com
but yeah man so uh I don't know man but
they you know maybe they didn't they did
a lot of violins back then
but
I don't know man I don't know about that
house of dragons
with the targaryens or whatever the [ __ ]
they're called
like I don't understand that that's the
thing about I don't part of it is okay
magic I'm not really into shows with
magic all right period the second a
wizard shows up I'm like okay
unrelatable
right
um or like you know
like I'm not really into that kind of a
thing I'm not into magic I'm not into
like sorcery
I'm not into somebody who can like
[ __ ] I'm not into like a woman who
predicts the future that everybody has
to go to in a tower to find out what's
gonna happen
and also if you're going to make up
a [ __ ] like uh a comp this is look
the story is all [ __ ] right like it
it didn't happen
right this is all [ __ ] it's from
some really creative [ __ ] guy's mind
right some real like you know
just
I don't know he looks like he would work
at a [ __ ] hardware store that Tolkien
guy or whatever and that's not even him
it's the other guy but whatever
um
and so
you're gonna make up [ __ ] right just
that's what it is in its true form it's
actual [ __ ] so that's fine
but why why are you making everybody's
name so hard to remember
and and and and letters that are
together that are never together
where you're like trageria jirian
could get terrarian chair Barian care
bearing
what the [ __ ] is that guy who is he
again and they all got white Air so you
don't know who's who so like work with
me you know what I mean if I'm gonna sit
and watch the show name him [ __ ]
Frank drebin
hello hi Frank hello Todd
whoa let let's let's go let's go on the
[ __ ] track
okay Todd shall we grab Lisa
Lisa who Lisa
Lisa Smith
wow yes that's right
it's not that I forgot her name because
it's very easy to remember it's that I
actually [ __ ] just didn't know it
crazy
[Music]
crazy
you're crazy
[Music]